ladies and gentlemen of NASA this is
Charles Xavier help is on the way doing
space missions now cool hyper one is
Charlie this is gonna be my non-spoilery
x-men Dark Phoenix review the very last
x-men movie from a fox with x-men in the
title we still have a new mutants coming
up later this year but during the video
I will address what the future of these
characters are and rank all my x-men
films from Fox but if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos it's gonna be crazy
the summer with spider-man far from home
there big Comic Con panel of d23 and all
the Avengers stuff that's happening
towards the end of the year big question
on everyone's mind going into the movie
is did they go out on a note like Logan
where you have arguably one of the best
films for that particular character
Logan itself is one of the best overall
x-men films in general not just one of
the best Wolverine films it just wound
up being a really amazing story
so did Dark Phoenix pull a Logan or is
it more like x-men the last stand which
is also a Dark Phoenix storyline or
x-men apocalypse arguably two of the
worst x-men films and I will start out
by saying that Dark Phoenix is no Logan
but thankfully it's also not Terra bad
like x-men The Last Stand interestingly
enough fomka was actually at the
premiere for x-men Dark Phoenix so you
get a lot of pictures with both versions
of the Phoenix and it reminds you how
long it's been since we've got that
original x-men franchise because fomka
is in her 50s now whereas all the
younger main characters are still in
their late 20s maybe early 30s with the
exception of the more senior characters
like Magneto Professor X and mystique
don't forget the first x-men film was
from back in 2000 so I think a lot of
the problems that the franchise has had
is that they've tried to remake the same
movie with the same group of characters
every single time instead of doing the
Marvel Cinematic Universe thing where
you try to build franchises for all the
different characters separately then
every couple years you team them up in
an Avengers movie due to embarrass me
from the Wizards so it took them a
little while to get to that spin-off
territory where you get films like
Deadpool which also consequently wind up
being some of the best x-men movies but
where is the first Dark Phoenix
storyline during x-men The Last Stand
had to compete with that mutant cure
storyline this time the dark phoenix
movie is just about Jean Grey's story
although it doesn't do some of the basic
things that you would expect it to do if
it's going to be from her perspective
because you're supposed to be getting
her journey this internal struggle that
she goes through and she's battling it
out with the Phoenix force in her dark
persona basic plot synopsis they go into
outer space to say some astronauts the
Phoenix force enters Jean Grey and then
she spends most of the movie slowly
losing a battle to her darker self as
the cosmic force within her of the
Phoenix starts to dominate her then you
have a couple different groups on planet
earth battling it out trying to decide
what to do with her before things get
out of control
you have Professor X the x-men then you
have magneto from Genosha with a proto
version of the Brotherhood of mutants
separately you have a group of aliens
through Jessica Chastain's character
that want to co-opt the Phoenix force
and use it for dark purposes so it
becomes a little bit of a Captain
America Civil War situation with a lot
of the earth-based mutants the x-men and
Magneto's Brotherhood of mutants as well
as some of the mutants within Professor
X's team just like the Avengers during
Captain America Civil War it's a really
messed up family with a lot of drama
between them a lot of things come to
light in Professor X's choices early on
and Jean Grey's life wind up fracturing
the team so the big question becomes do
they come back together to try and save
their friend Jean Grey how do they
resolve this situation and also deal
with these aliens that are trying to
take the Phoenix force so imagine x-men
The Last Stand if they didn't have any
of that mutant cure stuff going on and
it was just about the Brotherhood of
mutants versus the x-men for control of
Fon cos version of Jean Grey but the
thing is is that Michael Fassbender's
magneto isn't even that big of a
character during the movie they try to
use him as much as possible Michael
Fassbender is amazing but in a lot of
cases you'll find that the script just
isn't doing anyone any favors so magneto
doesn't seem like as big a deal as you
would think he would be in a movie like
this even how big a star Michael
Fassbender is because previously most of
the film's have focused on their Trinity
the three highest paid actors Magneto
Professor X and mystique because
Jennifer Lawrence became such a big star
in the last 10 years James McAvoy does
everything that he can with the script
he's a fantastic actor as well
I think it's a little bit easier for him
to work around any script problems but
Jennifer Lawrence's mystique almost
feels like she's just completely phoning
in her performance you can definitely
tell that she really wants out of this
franchise so she's barely in the movie
as well - and one of the biggest
problems the movie has is that early on
one of the biggest emotional twists that
the movie has to land trades a lot on
her relationship with the Jean Grey
character where the movies haven't
really established it that much
you saw her teaching them at the end of
x-men apocalypse so it's implied that
they spent a lot of time together
but the Dark Phoenix movie doesn't
really sell you on that idea so a lot of
the big twists don't really land that
hard
and even though sophie turner has gotten
way better as an actress on game of
thrones arguably where most of her best
work is being done regardless of how you
feel about the final couple seasons of
Game of Thrones even if you don't like
the way those scripts have gone down I
feel like sophie turner has made do with
a lot of the material she's been given
even though like the words per minute on
Game of Thrones has gone down
exponentially so she really hasn't
gotten all that much dialogue the last
couple of seasons her Dark Phoenix
performance winds up being kind of stiff
and they don't really give you that
internal point-of-view perspective that
you would expect to get if the movies
being centered on her character and
again I think the big problem with that
is is that they tried to fast-track this
Dark Phoenix storyline whereby with
Logan you actually had Hugh Jackman's
character for almost 20 years before
they tried to do the Logan story the
last Logan's story and this is meant to
be the last Jean Grey story think about
Ironman in the MCU in the way he went
out during avengers endgame how long
have we been living with Robert Downey
jr. version of Iron Man 10 plus years
they took 10 plus years in countless
movie performances in Maine starring
huge roles developing his character
whereas we barely just met so if he
Turner's Jean Grey during x-men
apocalypse and they're all sudden trying
to do Dark Phoenix right now like it's
meant to be this big culmination of a
huge arc that we've been watching for
the last 10 years when really we've only
got like 20 or 30 minutes total with her
character before this movie starts so
the big question becomes why do Dark
Phoenix because it's a big comic book
story in apparently big comic book
stories make good movies technically yes
but it'd be like trying to do Avengers
of
he wore an Avengers end game right after
you do the first Iron Man movie like you
just can't go there right away - this
really epic story that's meant to close
down a big x-men arc I don't know about
the direction but if you guys didn't
know the person that wrote x-men The
Last Stand is the person that directed
x-men Dark Phoenix he also wrote a lot
of the script - he was the producer
during the declining years of Bryan
Singer in the x-men universe when Bryan
Singer would just check out and not show
up to set while they were shooting x-men
apocalypse or x-men Days of Future past
like he was just completely check out
for a while
so because the movies are on a timetable
you still have to make him even if the
director isn't around other people would
have to fill in for Bryan Singer he was
the lead guy who did most of the work on
x-men apocalypse which still wound up
being a pretty bad film so it's like
they saw all the stories stuff that they
were setting up an x-men apocalypse and
said let's double down on that so
speaking of the script in the story what
happened is is they completely reshot
the end of the film the whole third act
which is a lot the reason they said that
they did that is because it was too
similar to the ending of a very recent
big Marvel movie they didn't say which
movie it was but I think what they were
talking about is the end of Captain
Marvel because at the end of the Captain
Marvel movie she goes into binary form
she blows up all these ships in outer
space there are aliens coming to try and
co-opt her so x-men Dark Phoenix is much
more grounded take on the character
whereas originally I think call it
deleted scenes or whatever it ended in
outer space with Jean Grey going full
Phoenix form blowing up all of Jessica
Chastain spaceships and just looking
almost exactly the same way that Captain
Marvel did at the end of her film
because they were trying to go with a
more grounded approach the action scenes
aren't quite as over-the-top and crazy
as the ones during x-men apocalypse but
they're not particularly outstanding
either like we're not talking about
Avengers infinity war Avengers endgame
level action scenes Nicholas Hoult did a
pretty decent job as beasts but the
movie doesn't give him a whole lot of
stuff to do
Evan Peters is Quicksilver is always a
fantastic performance he's always a
really great character to have in the
movie but he's barely in this movie and
one of the more interesting ideas that
they set up in the previous films is
that magneto is his father and he hasn't
talked to him about it yet
you might one day this movie does
nothing to forward that plot they don't
address Quicksilver dad Neto at all I
wasn't a big fan of ty Sheridan Cyclops
during x-men apocalypse this movie
doesn't really give him that great a
material to work with either there's
some real cringe-worthy moments but
because this movie is set during the 90s
if you were hoping for a Hugh Jackman
Wolverine cameo he's not in the movie
either in the way that they explain that
or the way they justify it is is they
didn't want to do the Wolverine Jean
Grey Cyclops love triangle again with
Hugh Jackman
even though Hugh Jackman is fantastic
because this version of Jean Grey Sophie
Turner's version is way younger and it
would be like having a 50-something
person have a romance with a young
20-something and it was just feel kind
of weird but I don't do the pudding
Wolverine in this movie would have made
it that much better or anything like
that so it's not like they're missing a
lot by not having Wolverine there is no
post-credit scene but you can see
through the credits just in case there
was no post-credit scene at the
screening that I went to I do give them
points for attempting to Logan there
x-men franchise go out and a really
grounded really a solid emotional note
but I feel like a lot of the stuff
they're going for they did not earn
especially given that you barely know
Jean Grey so it just doesn't quite land
on you as emotionally as it could have
had you lived with the character for
several more years but here's the thing
what's the future of these big
mainstream x-men characters within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe well I think
fair to say after you see this movie
you'll be like please just recast a lot
of them completely reboot the franchise
you don't need to bring anybody maybe
during Secret Wars you cameo Michael
Fassbender James McAvoy maybe Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine if he's willing to
come back as old man Logan but you wait
you know maybe solid 10 years before you
try something like that and what I think
they'll do because Kevin Feige is
already laid out most of Marvel phase 4
is that we won't see x-men pop up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe for at least
four or five years maybe even Marvel
phase five and then you start by doing
the spider-man Tom Holland thing where
you start with young versions of the
main older characters like Professor X
magneto Kitty Pryde Wolverine then once
they've aged up towards the end of the
next couple of phases you start to
introduce the other bigger characters
like
Jean Grae Cyclops in the rest as they
start to form their school all the
fantastic four characters Deadpool
that's all separate stuff so don't
consider to that when I'm talking about
x-men characters coming into the MCU
Ryan Reynolds Deadpool is probably the
only character from Fox that will
survive the transition to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe just because he's
done such a fantastic job with his
character in his movies character for
Marvel movies we are Marvel yeah but
you're you know Marvel license my Fox
it's like if the Beatles were produced
by Nickelback it's music but it sucks
but here's my ranking of all the x-men
Fox movies from worst to best so the
worst tears at the bottom x-men The Last
Stand x-men apocalypse x-men origins
Wolverine x-men Dark Phoenix The
Wolverine x-men 1 the original x-men
movie x-men Days of Future past
Deadpool 2 x-men first class still
probably the best x-men film with the
new cast then x2 which is still a great
film the first Deadpool movie and then
my favorite x-men film is Logan once you
have a chance to see the movie though
let me know what you think of Dark
Phoenix and tell me what your favorite
x-men movie is or your favorite couple
of x-men movies I'll be doing more
Marvel videos through the week I'll
probably do an x-men Dark Phoenix Easter
eggs video this weekend too but leave
your requests in the comments below
while you wait for everything click here
for my new spider-man far from home
trailer with a really cool new Iron Man
scene and click here for that brand new
Rick and Morty season 4 trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]